the king is trying to be all
three branches but the person who can be
trusted to be
all three branches is actually named in
the document
what is the general rule first paragraph
well it's the fact that because of
equality and because
all men are created equal under the laws
of nature they have the right to under
the laws of nature
and nature's god isn't that the first
authority cited
in this yes right and
christian over here mentions two other
places where god
is mentioned in the declaration what
were they
they were at the where were talked about
endowed with
inalienable rights by their creator as
well as the end when we pledged to each
other
by the name of our divine providence
divine providence
creator laws of nature
and of nature's god can you think of
[Music]
another
no so the answer is
supreme judge of the world
toward the end so what branch of
government would be the
maker of the laws of nature and of
nature's god
legislative lawmaker yeah right
god isn't a lawmaker right
what branch of government would be
supreme judge
of the world
yeah what branch of government would be
divine
providence executives
and the creator would be like a founder
right like a constitution maker
now it's very interesting that god
appears in these
guises and these images
the branches of government when one of
the charges in the middle of the
declaration of independence
is that the king who's the executive
branch
has interfered with the legislature and
the judges
he suspended the legislature he has
removed
judges he has interfered with the trial
by jury
the king is trying to be all
three branches but the person
who can be trusted to be all three
branches is actually
named in the document only god
right it's a very plain isn't it
now what would you mean by a law of
nature
kind of rules that govern how things
should operate
you can make it specific right this
that's good that's very good steve
and you can make it specific this way
too because uh
if we say that a thing has a way of
growing
well under what conditions does it grow
well
like plants need sun and you know
sequoia trees need space whatever makes
it
thrive that's the law governing it
and the laws of nature and of nature's
god
they're referring there to this god that
appears three other times
right the one responsible for the order
of all things
and also the great majority of them
the one to whom they pray
and expect them to protect the
revolution
that they're wasting not all of them
thought that god was so but many did
and we're going to learn as we go that
it was a specific purpose
of the united states of america to be
the first country
to make a complete and full and happy
home
for people who thought both ways about
that
because their idea was those who were
christians who were the great
majority of them their idea was
you're never going to get to heaven
because somebody passed a law saying you
had to do so
thank you for watching we hope you're
enjoying our highlight series and invite
you to explore all
of hillsdale college's online courses
they are free
and for everyone who loves to learn